it's always always good to see other
friends from other parts of the campus
at our conference and actually this
isn't our usual time but when we have a
distinguished guests we we accommodate
the time and just just for those of you
who are not regular attendees of de maiz
conferences we do we're an informatics
group so we stream these and we actually
let people who are out there in
cyberspace watching send us questions by
Twitter so we'll monitor the Twitter
feed if any questions come in I attended
one of our conferences from Riyadh Saudi
Arabia last month and managed to tweet
in a question and when you do ask
questions if you can press and hold down
the little button on the microphone that
enables the audio for people hear the
audio otherwise they can hear it and we
also record these and they appear on our
website so it gives me a great pleasure
to introduce Katerina tetris tetris
sorry who is visiting from the
University of Colorado Denver where
she's an associate professor in the
department of biostatistics and
informatics and works with the colleague
of ours Larry hunter who I've known many
years she received her PhD in statistics
from UC Berkeley and then did a postdoc
at the University of California San
Francisco and she's going to talk to us
today on regulation of the transcriptome
audiovisuals this this work fine great
well thank you for the introduction and
I also want to thank Shannon for setting
up this visit it's been a pleasure to
meet with some of you earlier today and
I look forward to talking to some of the
others tomorrow so the today i'll talk
about computational methods developed in
my group to study the regulation of the
transcriptome
but before I get into some the details
of the methods I wanted to first
introduce myself that I haven't had a
chance to meet I have training in
statistics mentioned and I'm interested
in the development of statistical and by
firm attics methods so it's my emphasis
on high-throughput data analysis and
related to that with my recent
collaborations who are their
investigators are using multiple
technologies to profile their systems
have been involved in integration of
different types of omics data which
poses challenges from the statistical
computational side I'm also interested
in the development of software methods
so that some of these methods can be
general for others typically working
stuff physical software are but also
another programming languages so that's
my interest from the statistical and
computational side from the biological
side I mr. stood in the processes that
regulate transcription the different
mechanisms whether they're the role of
transition factors or genetic effects or
post originally by micrornas and other
non-coding RNAs and as you know there
are many different types of technologies
array in sequence based for obtaining
genome-wide profiles of different stages
of these mechanisms getting expression
measurements for genes and non-coding
RNA looking at these DNA sequence to
look at binding sites for touching in
factors or micrornas the DNA methylation
profiles and other types of genome-wide
data so that's my interest again on the
biological side is these mechanisms that
are important for transcription
regulation but the statistics that the
biology what brings it together or the
collaborations I have with medical
investigators i'm currently at a medical
campus in order this environment so very
close work with biomedical investigators
i've highlighted two of my main
collaborations throughout the years
since i've started there One is using
animal models and behavioral models for
alcohol use disorders we there was a
several investigators and Denver and
Boulder always tie back off Paul Hoffman
Richard Radcliffe and Tom Johnson and
I'll talk a little about that later
today what I won't talk about is another
made collaboration with lung disease
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
this is
large human genetic epidemiology studies
were involved with different omics
profiling proteomics metabolomics and
trying to integrate the different
molecular profiles so as you see these
are very different disorders but there's
a common theme one is sort of a bad
things we do to our body that's
excessive drinking or smoking sort of
environmental exposures but the common
theme on my end I think is the
complexity these are both complex
diseases at the molecular genetic these
are polygenic disorders multiple
pathways involved but also complex
diseases to care to characterize whether
it's acute or chronic effects of ethanol
exposure or for COPD there's three types
of clinical metrics spirometry based or
CT scans so there's also complexity to
define the disease and there's work
involved in better characterization of
the complexity of the phenotype so those
are common themes for these
collaborations I just wanted to mention
a few others wide ranging from the role
of HPV and development of cancer to
fertility to obesity and diabetes again
I play similar role where I'm involved
with the regulation of the or the
analysis of the cartridge and regulatory
data I wanted since there's a such a
strong alcohol research group I wanted
to highlight some work with alcohol
researchers in Colorado before i get
into the some of the methods that i'll
talk about and for example this is a
study that's now been under revision
that's looking at selected lines for
alcohol preference and looking at
expression profiles during the selection
stages so we can look at the expression
profiles in conjunction with the alcohol
preference measurements but there are
throughout the years I've worked another
alcohol consumption and tolerant and
models and analysis of the gene
expression data again contributing to
the micro RNA sequencing analysis or
transition factor binding site analysis
also some work with Tom Johnson and
fetal alcohol syndrome models again
using mouse strains and sometimes it
says fart methods development when
to look at in this case it was a multi
treatment for multiple strains multiple
brain regions and looking at expression
at different times after exposure so so
to develop general models for that
purpose and have also contributed to the
pheno gen database website which is to
study complex diseases complex traits
and contributed to the modules in the
different database in the database for
related to expression analysis and
transition regulation so that's a
snapshot of my interest and what I've
been doing for the last eight years and
and I find the collaborations is the
most enjoyable aspect of my work this
pause the second pic I'm all now switch
gears if you have questions to actual
some of the methods developed I'll go
into more detail about some of the
methods developed in my group related to
the regulation of the transcript own I'm
using a very simple central dogma
diagram very simplistic to show with
information flow from DNA to RNA to
protein and then how these methods play
into that those different processes the
first method is related to the role of
transition factors this is important
regulatory proteins to initiate or
repress transcription and looking at
binding because the recognition of
transition factors of the binding sites
is important for their regulation of
regulating downstream targets will talk
about analysis of in vitro binding data
then that will lead to an analysis of in
vivo binding data so now you can there
are technologies to examine how we're
touching two factors on binding across
in the genome but this is geno my data
and it can also be used for the analysis
of DNA methylation based on arrays as i
mentioned before a lot of the labs I
work with are using different
technologies to profile their systems so
I've worked on development of methods
that integrate different omics level
data at different stages whether its DNA
sequence binding data or the actual
expression measurements talk a little
about that and finally look at post
translational processing so after the
RNA has been transcribed there are other
types of regulators
particularly non-coding RNA like micro
RNA spend some time but this is my most
recent work and come back to an alcohol
example so so I'll go through the
different methods in this order and they
also increase in terms of complexity in
terms of the each of these there's a
motivating example based on the
collaboration and starts from yeast and
bacterial in vitro binding examples to
using Drosophila as a model system for
studying development and finally to the
behavioral models and alcohol just look
at micrornas so start with the first one
which is called the method is called
SELEX interested review search engine
factors are important proteins that
recognize they are deemed a binding so
they recognize their binding sites near
target genes willing promoters and
here's an example of some binding sites
for a tragedy factor in East called gal
for responsive galactose rich conditions
and following this recognition they
interact with RNA polymerase and
different cofactors and multitude of
proteins to help initiate or repress the
transcription of target gene so that's a
role of transition factors as you go to
higher organism so in ease they're very
well studied a couple hundred are very
well studied go to higher organisms
there may be estimated up to fifteen to
seventeen hundred different DNA binding
titration factors and there are efforts
to try to elucidate their binding in the
genome but understanding their
particular binding preference like you
would see here is still there's still a
lot more work in that area and
understanding their binding specificity
helps to understand where they bind in
the genome so it's a problem of I'm just
important because you can look at
targets of particular chanting factors
and pathways once you have this
information so we used high-throughput
sequencing approaches to perform a
quantitative analysis and then develop
sort of a model for estimation of the
tension factor binding energies using
some biophysical properties
so before I talk more about method I
wanted to mention that there are smaller
scale approaches to study transition
funding binding in vitro gel shift
assays where you can look at predefined
sequences binding potential there's also
screeding based approaches like seelix
where you screen a random pool of all I
goes and try to in the screening assay
identifies those at higher binding so
these trying to find the highest binders
they're also moderately binding type the
sequences that may not be captured in
this approach in the last few years
seelix type approaches have been scaled
up so now we have next-generation
sequencing so we can now perform
paralyzed able looking at multiple
transition factors and looking instead
of a predefined small set of a few dozen
looking at thousands of hundreds of
thousands of possible all it goes that
may be binding to attach it to a factor
they have names like by Nancy core HD
selects helix week so it gives an
indication that they're building up on
the ceilings approach so we've worked in
this area as well and this is the method
is called sudoc simultaneous ultra high
throughput like and dissociation
experiment it's a mouthful so that's a
nice greevey a shin and the idea is that
you can mix random Ali goes first
without a transcription factor get a
baseline for what the frequency of those
all egos are and then you include the
transition factor and able to extract
the bound all egos and then so you can
see those okay and then you can compare
relative frequencies and then you can
identify the type of binding sites that
are preferred by the transcription
factor we used some biophysical
principles to model the frequencies to
estimate these binding energies kds
using a Bayesian model and markov chain
monte carlo to paint posterior estimates
of the mean binding values for each oh
we go here's this an illustration of the
data hypothetical cartoon here we're pre
binding this is before the Chechen
factor is included here's just a list of
some of the all egos continues you have
count before and then
the Chechen factors included and most of
the time you see this variation within
the noise between the two between pre
and post or even high levels that are
similar sometimes you see reduction I'll
talk about that later why that may occur
but the interesting cases are like this
where you see an increase so what the
Chechen factor is added that particular
Ollie goes enriched indicating that it's
possibly binding has a stronger
preference for that binding sigues we
can use some standard count based models
multinomial models where you have a
parameter for the frequency of each all
ago so we can have the pre bound
frequencies and the post band
frequencies and the overall count that's
the basic assumption we use for the
count it's a comment distribution for
counts but we wanted to incorporate the
biophysical properties okay so something
we know about how transition factors are
interacting with their DNA recognition
site so here's an in colibri 'um
reaction with a verse again we're taking
them despite themselves we had a tension
factor on the site sequence site so
here's free toucha to factor inside and
here's a clearing reaction where you
have bound site and then you go back and
forth with certain rate of binding and
dissociation again we're some
statistician I like to express this in
probabilities either express this as a
probability of binding just the
concentration of the bound versus the
total and there is this equilibrium
constant which is the quantity of
interest that's the rate between the
dissociation and the binding and that's
this ratio putting this all together and
I'm skipping the map hope you trust me
this can be expressed as if the same
probability as a function of two
quantities try to tune factor
concentration and this KD and so that's
the parameter of interest for each all
ago that tells you how would strong
binder it is and for those of you with
some physics background the KD can also
be expressed as a free energy of binding
a delta G term based using the simple
equation so we use these interchangeably
there they can be even go back and forth
using this set equation
so putting this all together here's an
illustration of our model and I know
there's a lot of equations and I heard
you lose half your audience for every
equation yeah so hopefully I thought the
case here but I wanted to highlight I'll
highlight the important parts of this
it's a graphical model version computer
science world if of the model so we have
our data these are these pre counts that
counts before and after I mentioned this
is multinomial that's the data we
observe that shaded we also have some
reference kds for at least 10 lego
that's important for calibration if not
you get relative metrics so this is
important for calibration I'll show
otherwise you'll get a relative Delta
Delta G so that's the data that's
observed and then there's parameters of
interest that I've talked about
retention factor concentration there's
these prebound frequencies we need to
know its baseline and then either the
Delta G or the KD you can go back and
forth and all the other intermediates
are just set by deterministic equations
there's no probabilistic relationships
there so we just need to go through
these intermediates so use the data to
estimate posterior probabilities of
these quantities and these will tell you
about again what kind of binding site
does that transition factor prefer again
that helps you understand possibly its
its targets in the genome now there are
some limitations to this approach if
there are low sequence there are low
count so it's sequencing data if you
don't do enough sequencing you may have
low count remember we're looking at
thousands of possible all it goes so
there could be estimations could be
inaccurate due to low frequency counts
and if you have hydrogen concentration
or low tension packed and constitution
that could be a problem and you can
think of it there's you have a lot of
tension factor concentration there's a
lot of them floating around and they're
going to bind kind of not specifically
if there's not enough then they will
bind to only the highest binders and if
you're familiar with position weight
matrix models those assume there's a low
transition factor concentration so it's
really biased towards the highest
binders and we wanted to model be a
little more flexible we wanted this to
be parameter in the model so that we
could look at more intermediate types of
binders so we have a model extension
that
pools information across all the data so
now you have a you have a contribution
based on every position in every every
nucleotide so you have some kind of
optimal binding energy and depending on
each nucleotide at each position you
have a contribution to the energy and
you can look at higher order terms we're
not doing that for some to keep things
simple but you can look at pairwise it
is known there are known to be
interactions between positions in a
tragic vector binding site so you can
expand this as well so that's the model
i'll discuss some some results there's
more in the paper where we had here to
transition factors again in these i
mentioned yeast and bacterial so I'll
totally more studied in bacteria and
yeast so we had some non kds and we
could simulate a repertoire of sequences
that you would observe in one of these
types of sequencing studies the pre
bound with sassoon equal frequency and
post bound you can use these known kds
and start to very these first of all how
much sequence are near to do this is
experimental design issue what kind of
precision do you have depending on how
much sequencing you do and also varying
the effect of the church' to a factor
concentration and I may have forgotten
to mention that you can't in the
experiment you can't necessarily set
that precisely and that's why it's
important for that to be free you can do
some follow-up assays to try to deduce
what the concentration is but it's not
something you can step precisely and
that's why I think it's important to
have it as a free parameter and we can
just look at the root mean square error
of prediction so how well do we predict
the known kds so here's an example of
one of the transition factors the x-axis
is the average count how much the Qin
thing so the more sequencing on the to
go to the right the y-axis is this root
mean square so that's how perform the
smaller the better we're predicting
better and the two models this basic
model and then this model that
degenerative energy model that pulls
information across positions is in red
so blue and red and so one trend you see
is definitely more sequencing more data
the better most always the case so that
was this confirmed here and
as you increase the transition factor
concentration you also increase the
error rate of that basic binding model
which is something we hypothesized that
would happen because this basic model is
more sensitive to check concentration
where the other one that y axis is
changing so you can see the red bars are
more stable they're less sensitive to
that particularly says something you
can't always control and in this case
the this extension model that pulls
information across the positions and
sites also performs better but this is
not always a case I can't forsake the
sake of time I can and show all the
results but rather tension factors that
bind in a different fashion you actually
get sometimes the basic binding model
that's better how does this relate to
the actual binding site again the
purpose of this is to understand the
specificity of a transition factor and
then try you can use that information to
look at buying possible binding sites in
the genome and look at target possible
targets so here are the posterior
distributions of these position specific
energy terms for lou three here's a
cartoon of its structure with binding to
its DNA here's a consensus binding sites
of here we know the true they want to
see how well we do so the columns are
different i see GT different nucleotides
the rows are the positions one through
ten across and the model actually tries
to find the optimal nucleotides that may
be occurring so sometimes some basis a
is not really meaningful if you convert
it to an a that it's not selected in the
model process so the most the optimal
binding energies here see which you
would see in the consensus and then if
you have a nucleotide substitution g or
t you can see the effect of that so t is
very deleterious so you have a high
additive component so if you observe a
tea there it will affect the interaction
between the tragic factor and the DNA so
this is probably the largest one in
other cases your position three you can
trade you go and not have that much
effect so that's how you can summarize
and interpret the outcomes of this model
and
and and you can move along that and see
the effects so that relates it to the
actual binding site so just to move
along in review and this is a method i
forgot to mention this is with David
Pollak's group and biochemistry
molecular genetics in Denver and this is
a software in see that's available on
his website and we've you know we come
across some issues with some of the
existing HTC likes or selig seek type
data is that the pre bound frequency so
I up to now is this saying oh well we
assume they're equal frequency but there
are a lot there's biases and how this in
the sequencing where there's some could
be some secondary structure that affects
which all egos are sequence more than
others so we found orders of magnitude
differences in some of the ollie goes in
the pre bound frequencies so forget the
transition factors naughty the mayor you
expect uniform distribution but there's
very large biases so we tried to account
for that building a third order Markov
model so to try to get more accurist
frequencies and and you can see there's
based on some of these structural issues
that you get some DC bias or so they're
not evenly sequencing the pre bound
Ollie goes so that needs to be accounted
for or else your later estimates are
biased and this approach can be used for
experimental design issues dependence
the count you could see is the more data
you how much sequencing would you need
to do and what kind of concentration
would you need so and what's the lay the
nutrition factor binding site so it
provides a platform for exploring all of
this that concludes the introduction to
the Sewell decks method that again I
mention is in vitro binding and we had a
yeast Nicole I example so now I'm going
to increase in complexity so I'm going
to start looking now at in vivo binding
a touch of in factors genome-wide and
have a there's a fly developmental model
for for that motivated that problem so
the method is called compy the
motivating example is with collaboration
with the kornberg lab at UCSF they look
at the fly development and the pathway
they're looking at is
hedgehog here's Hedgehog and he there's
a down strange hydrogen factor CI that's
involved in activating several pathways
involved in development particularly
wing development and the hedgehog
pathway is also important this for
development you there's a homologous
pathway in human sonic hedgehog and
that's also been implicated in the
development of cancer disease
implications to so CI is right here
that's the Chechen factor of interest
and you can see when you have a well
type wing compared to a mutant see I
wink it's smaller there's some veins
missing and all that affects the
function of the wing so CI is an
important component of this pathway and
proper regulation of the downstream
targets so they were interested in
identifying targets of CI and they had
had a performed a in vivo binding assay
they start damn ID and tiling and I'll
go into that in the next slide the my
role was predicting regions of high CI
binding levels in the genome problem is
that there were very strong spatial
dependencies as you moved along the
genome with this type of data it was
important to account for that otherwise
you getting we would get a lot of false
positives so this is a review remember
you're familiar with chip chip method
chips ray chip chip or chip seek so this
is a high-throughput methods for the
isolation and identification of DNA
sequences found by a DNA binding protein
for example transition factor in this
case across the genome in the sand
illustration of the method the chip
method here is based on Mona antibody
approach they had an alternative called
damn idea I can't get into the details
but in that case antibodies not needed
and that's the advantage of using that
so that's an alternative here and now
instead of arrays often sequencing is
used but the end goal is similar in that
you're trying to find Peaks along the
jam that are possibly targets and of
this transition factor so for the array
data this is what they had generated
here's this illustration of the data you
have the chromosome probes across and
there are chipped DNA bound regions or
damn ID that are pained by those regions
that are bound by the tradition factor
and then there's some controls that
should be randomly distributed in the
genome in blue
so that peak analysis would be finding
series of enrichment of bound versus
control so look at a ratio and hear much
more frequencies of the signal for the
ship enriched in versus the control so
analysis method there's mentioned the
challenges of the spatial dependencies
the bound that's DNA sequence that's
obtained is much longer than the probes
themselves so you get spatial
dependencies there and the methods have
been developed for example they may rely
on hidden Markov models I try to capture
some of the local relationships but they
can't capture to long-range they tend to
be one or two or three positions and
moving averages are simple but more
intuitive and the show you an example
here's with say the original values of
probes some ratios and you're just
moving along calculating and moving
average as you go along and find high
values so much more simpler but also
intuitive for interpretation now the
limitations of the moving average is a
tent they are not very convenient for
alternative types of analyses and this
came up because i had a another
collaboration where it was a large human
cohort he had a lots of clinical
variables you need to adjust for those
so having more complicated modeling was
important or maybe nonparametric
statistics or more complex studies the
moving average was based basically on
this ratio the other issue was a
correlation among the probes and this is
not corrected it could could inflate
significance so then I'll show you here
an example from the flight data here's
the lag of the probes so we have one lag
to lag and you can calculate the
correlation so of course that probe
itself zero lag it's one no y axis and
the next flag one you have correlation
point six so it's pretty strong it drops
off eventually for damn ID data this is
particularly stronger because the damn
ID method identify regions are longer
than chip okay so it was an issue for
their data set that I needed to address
because if that was not addressed we
would get lots of predictions a month
and they tended to be false positives so
we needed to make these adjustments
but I worked on was a generalized moving
average taking the ideas of the moving
average since there's their intuitive
and help you can explain them much
easier than a hidden Markov model so the
idea was to use a p-value at each probe
for particular test and then you can
incorporate the complex analysis
whatever it is with the human study you
need to make adjustments or not
parametrics test you can also account
for direction using a one-sided test now
there it's not appropriate to take
averages p values since are distributed
between 0 & 1 so you can draw from the
meta-analysis literature so here I have
one example that I tried different types
but they're called combined p-values so
ideas you take a p-value at each probe
and you can convert this using the
Gaussian cumulative distribution
function and then that can be averaged
because it's called this to feel
attacked s and there's some alternatives
that I also tried so now I have a moving
average of something I can actually
calculate a moving average of so I
converted the p-values into something
that you can actually take an average of
and then use standard theory for for
averages now the other problem was the
correlations and it depends on the type
of test so to show you this particular
one for the the one that I just
described where you converted the
p-values into Q or Z values I think of a
Z values well we have this correlation
matrix they're highly correlated and
again if you don't correct with this it
causes problems I won't go into them I
won't go into the map but after some
transformations and some matrix algebra
you can make them so that they're now
independent and follow standard normal
distribution and then use all the
standard theory so again another
transformation to make them usable so
that was the crux of approach I also
tried alternative combined p value
statistic an alternative Corrections but
this shows you the general approach once
you have these combined p value averages
you can as you move along the genome you
can look at the significance you can
look at this moving average and define
Peaks also correcting for multiple
testing and for now I just use a set
cutoff that the probe should be within a
certain distance
although I've relaxed this in future
work so now you can define a region of
the genome that shows this trend
associated with your test of interest I
have here a diagram showing that you
have these adjusted p-values moving
along and this is would be the window
that shows the biggest trend okay so
whatever the test you are performing
this is all in the same direction shows
a string of values that are consistently
significant to evaluate methods of
foreign partner with my informatics
researches we have ideas but you can
always know if they're working because
you don't always have gold standards and
less I mean you can do simulations which
are great start so trying to find how to
evaluate this approach was important I
work closely with the lab there and they
they had a list of predicted gene
targets of CI some of these very well
curated for an experimental literature
and others the they had were from
expression data maybe predictions on
their part so we can examine the
predicted peaks for whether they're
close to target genes and look whether
that was expected in the total genome
because of course these peaks by chain
random chance they may be occurring near
target genes so you need to correct for
that the other evaluation was
fortunately for CI there is a consensus
binding site that's GD GD feeling GT
rich and we can examine the currents in
Peaks or scaled by the lane because this
is a pretty short motif it's going to
occur randomly in the genome we need to
correct with that here's some
representative results there's a lot of
lines here but I'll break it down the x
axis is different significance threshold
so that as you move to the right more
significant correcting for multiple
testing y axis is these two metrics
target gene enrichment and motif
enrichment and the lines are the
different methods so I'll highlight
first the bottom lines okay this is when
no dependence was built into the method
using both the methods that I proposed
and some of the existing methods in the
literature a basic moving average and
then hmmm and these both when you don't
account for dependence in the facial
across the genome you get less target
gene interruption less motif enrichment
what's happening is even at this very
stringent professional you were
predicting thousands of Peaks orders of
magnitude more than if you had the
dependents so picking up a lot of noise
and that's reflected here is that
there's a picking up a lot of random
peaks in the genome that are not near at
least the known target genes so that's
why this these metrics are reduced once
you include the enrichment you get much
more sumon Direction much more
enrichment you're getting peaks near
genes that are more meaningful based on
what they've provided more motifs so
that it's and you're just making less
predictions so just fine-tuning the
predictions among the methods the ones
that have proposed on the circle in the
Triangle and those perform better for
the more significant thresholds this is
a basic moving average and later for Lee
stringent thresholds they're more
similar with the slight advantage of the
basic moving average but like I
mentioned the basic moving average
doesn't allow from our complicated
models exist ratios or maybe a t-test
analysis so this is this illustration we
tried it on other data sets and
different examples now this method has
evolved again I was interacting with a
group of lung researchers on campus who
are looking a lot of epigenetic effects
so environmental effects to explain for
example asthma so they had an asthma
study and they were doing epigenetic
profiling using methylation chips this
is this picture from the alumina chip
that they use where you have probes for
the methylated state we had my family
estate and they they like this idea but
we need to work on making it more
adaptable for example probes are very
really spaced with methylation data
these chips because they're at cpg low
sigh that are not the same location or
the same spacing you had to account for
that being more dynamic and flexible to
define your peaks and I signing a
p-value for the actual peak itself but
with something of limitation before so
and at doing a multiple comparison at
the peak level not the probe level so
those are the ways we Depp did it to to
make it more suitable for the type of
methylation chips and also these these
were human studies this is the kind of
study that I mentioned you need to
adjust for clinical demographic
it's and this is a Python script that's
at the github site that's available and
I've seen it used in i mentioned i'm
involved copd research in some tea will
be the applications as well there aren't
any questions or Twitter questions like
I can take a pause okay is moving along
so so I talked about nitrogen factors
and methylation and again those are
important that mechanisms that can
regulate transcription the third method
I'll talk about is data integration is
how how can different data be combined
for one study to try to get better
inference so the example here I have
data integration both at the DNA level
the transition factor binding level and
also the expression data and this
approach is called healthy mix and it
was used the Hedgehog see I study as a
motivating study again although it's had
other applications and I just wanted to
highlight this was a PhD student working
with me who is on an LM training grant
this one to hide similar I think to the
women you have here and he just
graduated lost last fall so I wanted to
acknowledge his work on this and the
goal with the same how do identify CI
targets for this pathway but now we have
not only the binding data there's
expression data several mutants of the
CI the this pathway actually some in
earlier proteins involved in the pathway
and also sequence conservation so in
this case is a development it's highly
conserved among fly species and there's
a there's a fly species alignment with
mosquito and honey bee in UC Santa Cruz
you could look at conservation as well
the idea was to develop an integrated
model to use all that information to
obtain targets for CI so approach we
used here was a hierarchical mixture
model in the hierarchical part is that
this is the you have the observed data
here binding expression conservation and
what's unknown is whether a particular
gene is a target or not but whether it's
a target or not then you may expect
binding or not binding or expression
changes or non expression changes or
differences in conservation so that's
the hierarchical part and you can look
at different organizations different
topologies this one treats the different
processes in the same equally where this
approach tries to you supplementing the
biological knowledge that if it's a
target of CI the Hedgehog pathways and
it would maybe you have CI binding and
you know target gene and then that
expression the target gene changes and
then that expression may be selected on
and it may be reflected in the
conservation so that's more looking at
the process and the flow of the process
so you can have different topologies and
these are the two main topologies we've
looked at these are part of bayesian
belief network so you can you can think
of more other kinds of topologies but we
focused on these the mixture part is
that you expect different distributions
so here are known targets that were
collected from our collaborator binding
is shifted for the known targets and the
binding is for non own targets is
centered around zero okay so this is
called a mixture model where you have
two distributions so each of these you
can have different distributions whether
you're bound or unbound differential
expressed up regulated or flat or
downregulated so you can have 33
mixtures so there's flexibility in
allowing for different types of
different numbers of distributions to
reflect the different states so model
feeling was performed used using
expectation maximization to fit each of
the individual data types and then
looking at an extended am algorithm to
pick between the topologies we don't
know in advance what may be better fit
and there's model selection procedures
for that but I won't go into so I first
use some simulations but to try to mimic
the CI binding data and these are the
summary of them those main results where
if the predictors were all equally good
the layered model was treated them
equally tend to do better which is
expected if you had a poor predictor of
animal conservation is not a
particularly good predictor for CI it
has some information but to be yeah
other types of genes are conserved in
other develop at ways or other kinds of
pathway CI
it's not the only reason you would see
conservation so it's not not saying
conservation would not necessarily be
the best predictor but it is informative
so a chain model when maybe the
corporate victors are at the end would
perform better and then we looked at
some of the model fitting approaches
more the bite for Maddox's how to
implement this in the best way and we're
going to that so here's an example of
one of the data sets see I the CIA one
which was a motivating one so the x-axis
is this the percent predicted so we have
about 10,000 jeans and depending on
different posterior probability cut off
you predict a neighbor a number of of
jeans depending on the threshold and the
stringency and we don't quite have
negatives I know maybe you're familiar
with roc curves well we don't really
have negative so we can't do a proper
ROC curve but this is this how many
predictions were making overall and the
y-axis is we had a curated said about 70
targets for this pathway and we want to
see how well we did predicted those so
being up here is good of course those 70
benchmark set is not the only possible
targets they're just the ones that have
been know so far so you want to be
somewhere in here each of the individual
types are green blue and turquoise the
conservation as I mentioned is the worst
is that the motion informative to
identify targets although it's got some
predictive value expression was better
but not as strong as we thought binding
was actually the best in this particular
example my name is very strong and I
think it's the way the CI is it's a
single traction factor in this pathway
and it's very direct its role the
chained fit so this is the model that
was picked to be the best that's the red
line so there's a boost in performance
it's so it there is a contribution of
including expression and conservation
binding alone is not as good but you can
improve more and we looked at some of
the top jeans and with the integrated
model we were finding a pathway so we
looked at kegg pathway the gene ontology
that were very reflective of
developmental processes that he would
expect and they were more enriched using
the integrated model and just using each
data type individually so it showed the
power of using an integrative approach I
had other
example they don't have time to show but
other transition factors in Drosophila a
yeast another yeast example and it's not
always clear that this is the best model
sometimes the layered model was picked
so in advance you don't always know at
least based on the data which would
maybe as a flow of information so this
is available as an r package called LC
mix and it's a general model it's not
for any number of data types it's not
limited to those three different
distributions we had one example that we
tried that had count data so it would be
appropriate for sequencing data may be
long tail distributions of some of the
non-traditional distributions and
sometimes that reflect the kind of array
data what you see multivariate so we had
one example multiple binding data
multiple experiments or multiple
expression experiment and we're working
on a semi-supervised approach this is
considered unsupervised we can't do
supervised because we don't have a
negative tested but we can use maybe
those positives that will hi curated set
of 70 examples to maybe help inform the
algorithm okay to help prediction and
new applications this has been applied
going back to this asthma example we're
here they had methylation data and
transcriptome data this quickly talk
about this or 100x100 the Maddox and
hundred controls and blood and a gene
list of brooch studying each data type
separately trying to intersect had very
little results or almost none just had
low power so then they applied the
integrative approach and were able to
find many more genes and they were
related to some of the pathways they
expect for asthma so like I said it can
be used in other applications
so finally I will not talk about so this
up to this point has been all about
transcription looking at gene expression
looking binding 2010 factor binding and
methylation rule methylation the last
topic is post on tribunal processing so
I group that together although
technically this is after the
transitional process so one form of
Patricia neural processing is controlled
by micrornas okay so that's a current
area of research for me that I've been
excited about I'll talk about and how it
got into this and some current projects
and to sketching out the ideas and here
i'll come back to out the alcohol
research i mentioned i have this
long-standing collaboration with alcohol
researchers in denver in Boulder so the
motive example here is these behavioral
models and this this is the group i work
with looks at alcohol consumption these
animal models and they're interested in
identifying the predisposing genetic
factors for voluntary alcohol
consumption so one of one of the models
that they look I do other ones like
tolerance and sensitivity and the data
that we examine is there's a genetic
data for the different strains of mice
these are all my studies mouse studies
the transcript own data obviously the
behavioral data and all on in this case
recombinant into panels and my role is
contributing to the dynamical genomic
techniques to identify candidate genes
that predisposed to this behavior so
highlight one of the studies the
drinking in the dark model that relies
on the rodents normal patterns of eating
and drinking so there these animals are
provided ethanol during their dark cycle
hence the name and there was the
behavior was collected on several
strains and on a recombinant inbred
paddle that we call lexa so it's a cross
between the long and bread and the short
inbred strains and I'll highlight one of
the candidate genes that was sort of the
motivating story so this one candidate
gene GMD one came up in several analyses
of this drinking in the dark and also
other models of alcohol preference and
consumption it's guanine nucleotide
binding protein beta wants to immunity
and it's important because the
transducer singles signals from g
protein-coupled receptors that's its
role as the signal transducer so here's
in one of the figures from the alcohol
consumption work where they measured
gene expression levels four pairs of
strength so the X at the x axis is pairs
of strains one is a high alcohol
drinking when is low alcohol drinking so
red is low that's the red high is blue
and the expression what's reported here
is relative to the high up to the low
alcohol drinking in red so those are a
hundred percent so you see a reduction
in the high alcohol drinking mice in the
levels of G and V 1 transcript levels
for the most part I'll get back to this
anomaly here when you look at protein
levels similar pattern this is based on
an antibody based assay again lower
levels in the high alcohol drinking mice
so these are for example high alcohol
preference elected lines 1 2 3 these are
classical strains and this is this
parental strains of the panel that i'll
be discussing so as you notice there's
this one anomaly here it's pretty strong
so to pose the interesting question why
is this one different and especially the
protein levels bounce back and they're
consistent why are the what's reversing
here so I was interested in this because
i was getting i getting more into micro
RNA related research because that could
be one possible explanation there could
be others but perhaps there's a role of
a micro RNA here or one or more so do my
granny's play a role
yes so it's yes you're here is this it's
related to the gathered Eric system yeah
I know that's not I'm getting more onto
the role of the micro RNA so I know I
know it's translucency signals from the
g-protein coupled receptors and has a
role in this gaba system persistent yeah
yes and unfortunately I this is not my
expertise so I I focus more on the
analysis but and either there are if you
want more details in the paper they've
gone into depth about the possible
pathway and all the different mechanisms
so going back to micro RNAs this is a
review these are small and John and John
John is non-coding RNAs they can they
regulate target transcripts either
promoting transcript degradation or
repressing translation so in this in
this example the hypothesis would be
repression of transfer the translation
process so that the protein levels would
be reduced they are transcribed from the
genome and they drive from transcripts
that then fold back onto themselves to
get this interesting a hairpin structure
here now these like I said they target
genes and is a review they target genes
to be clean the three prime utr so
here's an example of the targeting so
there's the cleve version and which is
short 10 to 20 bases and there's some
base pairing although it's not perfect
and there's some secondary structure
involved with the actual target binding
now there are experimental resources
collected based on there's different
kinds of assays to look at binding gnb
one so that's the candidate gene is not
in any of these experimental databases
so there is not an exam known waste role
of any micro RNA regulating g and b
whining and these are collected from
human and mouse resources their
computational based methods so they look
at these the book the biophysics of this
interaction they look at the base
pairing again allowing for some
mismatches they look at conservation
across species and they come with a
metric for prediction and there's
different algorithms I won't get into
them there's at least a dozen they're
out there with nice databases that they
provide computational resources but if
you go into each of any of these and our
family you have there are thousands to
hundreds of thousands predictions there
there's a lot of information there are a
lot of predictions and there have been
compilations to try to make sense of
those to put them together they tend to
rely on set cut-offs and but they also
tend to be web servers so they're not
very fairly convenient to do a lot of
the downstream analysis that we would be
interested in so this was sparked a side
project a lot of the micro RNA research
was relatively more in cancer you don't
see as much in alcohol research there's
one very nice study of mere nine in the
alcohol research community it's
regulates its been it was found in rat
striatal neurons and regulates different
spice forms of the BK channel that have
different sensitivity or difference at
the tivity to ethanol and it's a very
nice story that's been oiled up with
multiple molecular studies and that's
probably the best well no studying the
alcohol research community and like I
mentioned a lot of it's in my in camp
sir so there's more in cancer so a lot
of these databases are also biased
towards more cancer related resources
now I had because of the cancer
connection I had started to interact
with some of the cancer researchers who
were studying micrornas and they were
coming across the same problem I was and
about this usability some of these
resources so I had a I had my own
compilation and I worked with a poop
stuck in the Cancer Center to take that
and create our package that can be
usable and to facilitate this type of
analysis so this was sort of a side
project it's under revision right now
and it it collects millions of record
different databases it has drug and
disease information in addition to the
computational and experimental resources
it also allows for more control and that
we try to have user-defined cut-offs so
that
we can control maybe the strength of
those predictions every algorithm has
its own threshold and type of summary so
we wanted to try to look at and try to
control that ourselves so so previous
version of that package I'll return out
of the GMP one story okay go back to the
DMV one story so here's a snapshot from
UC Santa Cruz showing the location of
jnb won the UT arch this is a UT are in
the genome and we're interested is where
is this probe set so here's a probe set
so it was an athlete metrics array that
measure the expression data so the probe
set actually was occurring that show
differential expression in the gutiar so
it's important to go and go into more
detail to find especially with these
arrays where are these perps that's
located so it's actually in the long
form of this utr there's a shorter form
as well and based on this compilation I
had created there were multiple
predicted micron a sites supported by
multiple algorithms these were the 22 18
and 101 a be the hypothesis was that
perhaps one of these two micro RNAs are
targeting gnb one in the high the high
alcohol drinking strain to repress
translation show that protein expression
then was reduced and then you had
consistency with the other types of
strength so I I worked with the micro
RNA gore on our campus recent analysis
left again she worked in cancer but she
had a special qrt pcr assay that she had
developed to look at my current
expression that was the first question
as well are these microRNAs expressed in
these in the brains this is all brain
brain of these strains and Richard
Radcliffe independent were very generous
in giving some samples so I could
control innate with Lynn and she looked
at the mic RNA expression levels in
their model they had the strains had
were alfo ethanol and saline-treated but
he also had my Eve and you could look at
the strain effect so we really wanted to
the strain effect not that has an all
treatment effect so here's some of the
preliminary results looking at strain
train effects for these two micrornas
with we did Cyril to increase in the
expression level of the micro RNA in the
high alcohol drinking
great okay which was the hypothesis that
we proposed they barely cut off barely
survived a point 05 threshold but we
thought this was good for a pilot data
and there was almost a two-fold change
so this helped support
what we would have more power I get to
see more well yes so we don't have much
power this was based and it was also not
ideal because we had other straight we
had another ethanol in tsaile treated
but of course like that was this I could
get ahold of so if I want to I would do
this again having a larger n for dust
the naive in the tude and the two
strains so you would have more you would
have more power yeah we had more power
to detect these smaller differences so
it was more of a pilot study there's
some limitations because it was this
what we could get at the time what was
given to me so i think it was motive it
would help motivate a larger study and
and that's the summary you have the high
alcohol drinking mice longer form of the
J&B 1 transcript and then at least
suggestive higher levels of the micro
RNA what we're working now with Lynn is
I've done this in a month in the COPD
study is looking at a binding fa so that
would be the next test is this micro RNA
so it seems to be expressed and maybe we
can improve the data and improve the
study but what's also look at binding of
the parent micro RNA in in the utr which
env once so there's a luciferase based
finding a say that we've done with the
COPD study in some other candidate genes
for one disease but the idea would then
to do that next here to now look at the
binding agreement natural binding so all
this sparked my interest to I like I
like you know that story was one story
one candidate gene was well maybe we
could find other examples like that so
idea was to look at the entire panel so
this is the history of how this panna
was determined using the spider
eccleston selection for differential
sensitivity to sedative effects of
ethanol so there's a whole panel of up
to 60 strains derived from those
parental strains the ILS and ISS there's
extensive genotyping based on a stipper
a diversity panel and mouse there's now
Richard crackles has a whole genome
sequencing of the two parental strains
there's dozens of alcohol-related
phenotypes and focusing here on alcohol
preference but there's also a set the
sensitivity intolerance and there's the
brain whole brain gene expression
available and again Richards doing RNA
seek on the panel for he has another
model which has includes ethanol as
saline and ethanol treated mice so the
goal but so you receive funding for was
to now profile micro RNA do this more
systematically particularly this case
study and scale-up profile multiple
micro RNA to identify other potential my
car and a regulated pathways like that
so we had Mike Ronnie and the gene which
would be associated with the
predisposition to alcohol intake like
the phenotype I've talked about but also
response and I've just completed some
Mike RNA expression profiling so this is
small RNA profiling using alumina high
seek on 66 of the strains just using
some of the extremes to start with and
hopefully presenting that at RSA for
those of you who go there but the
computational methods are how do we
integrate the micron expression we have
the gene expression of genetic data and
haverhill data together and this is what
this picture slide shows is here's one
example phenotype the distribution of
the loss of righting reflex we have the
parental strains but then there's a
spectrum from all the other strains you
can see a pretty wide variety rin
diversity of this particular phenotype
the data can be represented here we have
gene gene data my carne data we have
these interactions between genes and
micro RNA based on that multi mere
package that comp files that you look at
protein-protein interaction there's all
the genetic data and some of the methods
have been developed to look at gene and
micro RNA expression and look at
negative correlations some of those
methods are not so focused on the
disease or outcome or the phenotypes I
think emphasizing that would would be
contribution and linking it with all the
genetics so that's a sketch of future
work and
I woodland that concludes my talk I'd
like to wrap things up a little over
this they so these are group members
students and research assistants in my
group I didn't talk at all about the
copd data that I have some students
working on that alcohol researchers and
I'd also forgot to put Beth Bennett
she's been very she's taught me a lot
about so these behavioral phenotypes and
various collaborators I've mentioned
throughout the talk and finally funding
my funding from previous k grant and now
an ro1 and support by an LM 20 grand for
many of these students thank you for
your time so we we're about at the hour
we probably have time for one or two
questions please press the microphone
button down so it gets recorded I'll do
a quick one in the soul Dex method did
you ever run into a problem of having of
degenerate sequences after you've after
the transcription finder transcription
factor is bound to some sequence you
pulled it down did you ever have trouble
mapping that to the genome like a map to
more than one place that was not there
were those were never bound I mean never
mapped to the genome it's in vitro so
it's just looking at the theoretical
properties of binding so it's again in
theory what would this transition factor
by to now a random sequence yes they're
random pools of all egos but that's
important because in the genomic context
that could affect binding and some of
the some titration factors have
cofactors and so you could affect local
context in the genome so that's why the
invivo binding data is important
important although that resolution is
not it's several hundred basis so we
have better resolution with in vitro
assays but more genomic context but less
resolution in an in vivo so they both
have their pluses and minuses
okay thanks